today on the Matt wall show we talk
about lies damned lies and studies the
left tells us to follow the science but
often manipulates quote the science to
fabricate the desired result that's
certainly the case with a new study
proving quote unquote that gender
reassignment surgery is a wonderful
thing for children we'll talk about that
also some students in Virginia walk out
in protest against policies that make
them safer and protect their privacy Don
Lemon embarrasses himself gloriously yet
again on camera and people seem to be
very concerned about a sex scandal
involving something called the try guys
in our daily cancellation gen Z has
found a new way to Rebrand laziness
we'll talk about all that and more today
on the Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
Court decision to overturn Roe is a huge
albeit long overdue step in the right
direction but there's still a long way
to go to get rid of of abortion in our
country we got a long fight still to
fight many companies are bowing to the
woke mob unfortunately by donating to
pro-choice causes and candidates or
reimbursing their employees travel
expenses so that if they live and work
in a pro-life State they can travel to a
pro-abortion state get an abortion be
back at work on Monday but what if I
told you that if you're currently on a
phone plan with one or more major
carriers you might be supporting these
companies and their pro-abortion agendas
with your monthly phone bill don't let
abortionists use your money to fund
policies you don't believe in switch to
Charity mobile instead Charity mobile is
a pro-life pro-family cell phone company
that sends five percent of your monthly
plan price to the pro-life charity of
your choice you don't have to compromise
on values or a good phone service for
that matter Charity mobile offers the
latest 5G phones no device or service
contracts great Nationwide coverage and
Live customer service based right here
in the USA the fight for the right to
life continues and pro-life causes need
your support more than ever you can help
by simply switching your phone service
to Charity mobile today call
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com to mention offer
code walls to redeem a free cell phone
that's charitymobile.com and mention
offer code Walsh
well there are many ways to lie to tell
a lie in the modern world but few
methods are more effective than the LIE
told through in allegedly scientific
study people these days are obsessed
with studies every argument online
devolves into a food fight with each
side flinging studies at each other and
the great thing is that no matter the
topic and no matter what opinion you
hold about that topic you can always
find a study that supports what you
already believed that's what's so
fantastic about it
um this is what research usually entails
when a person claims to have researched
a topic and they start claiming that you
should do your research I've done my
research but what they really mean is
they
they went to Google they typed in their
opinion into the search bar and then the
word study and then they accept it as a
fact whatever results popped up first
I mean nobody actually reads the studies
nobody even reads the abstract or a few
lines of the introduction they probably
don't know that studies have abstracts
or introductions they don't even know
what a study is exactly all they need is
a media headline about the study
and they will of course immediately
discard any headlines about studies that
came to the opposite conclusion from the
one they wanted so they could sift
through uh 10 different headlines and
nine of them are talking about studies
that that contradiction contradict them
and they'll they'll they'll Zone in on
that one study that confirms what
they're saying and then that's all the
proof they need they just need that one
headline about one study and that's
enough for them to consider their entire
Viewpoint Vindicated
and now they can accuse everyone who
disagrees with them of not doing their
research and not following the science
what they don't realize and probably
wouldn't care if they did realize
is that a huge number of studies are to
put it scientifically
um bullcrap very often studies that
arrive at positive conclusions about a
certain thing or a certain practice
are funded by companies that produce the
thing or engage in the practice
and no matter who funds the study there
is no law or legal policy requiring that
the supposed researchers conducting the
study actually follow anything
resembling the scientific process anyone
can call anything a study
a few years ago I mentioned this before
there's a nine-year-old boy conducted an
informal survey
of a few plastic straw manufacturers and
arrived at the conclusion based on his
estimate from these conversations that
Americans use 500 million plastic straws
a day and the media trumpeted it as a as
a study proving that Americans use 500
million plastic straws a day and that
study which mostly consisted of a fourth
grader making up statistics for a school
project was used to pass legislation
across the country banning plastic
straws every time you go to a restaurant
now and you use a paper straw that
dissolves in your soda within 30 seconds
um well it's because of this study which
was not really a study at all but this
is how studies work
and the other thing you often notice
about them they tend to arrive at the
most convenient times
which brings us to this headline from
from CBS News this was published last
night
quote Top surgery drastically improves
quality of life for young transgender
people
study finds
wow now I mean that is great timing for
the left isn't it the practice of
Performing double mastectomies on minors
has come under intense scrutiny we're
working on a legislation to ban it in
this state and what do you know
turns out that um studies prove that a
girl's physical well-being can be
greatly improved by cutting a breasts
off just like that I mean they needed a
study they didn't have one they needed
one and there you go they have it
wow
CBS reports quote the quality of life of
young trans masculine people
dramatically improves after receiving
Top surgery a mastectomy procedure that
removes breast tissue according to a
study by Northwestern Medicine the study
published in the peer review journal
Jama Pediatrics on Monday is the first
to show that Top surgery is quote
associated with significant Improvement
in chest dysphoria gender congruence and
Body Image in transmasculine and
non-binary teens and young adults the
study compared two groups of patients
ranging in ages from 14 to 24.
quote when we compare the outcomes of
patients who receive gender affirming
Top surgery to those who did not we
recognize that surgery significantly
improved the quality of life for
patients said Dr sumanas Jordan who's
the director of the gender Pathways
program at Northwestern Medicine
wait a second but I've I've been
reliably informed that children aren't
undergoing gender reassignment surgeries
how could they have studied patients
ranging in ages down to 14. I thought
that wasn't happening
oh well it's because the left has now
made the official and inevitable
transition from that thing isn't
happening to okay that thing is
happening but it's good
it's certainly a suspicious move but I
mean if the science proves that removing
the healthy breasts of 14 year old girls
is good
who am I to disagree
the science has spoken hasn't it
well no not at all not even a little
so let's now dive into this because this
story offers I think kind of a clinic in
how to deceive in the form of a study
now if you look beyond the headline you
don't even look you don't have to look
that far beyond the headline but if you
look just just right beyond the headline
there are a few glaring issues which
jump out right away first of all once
again
always look at who is funding the study
in this case the study was conducted by
the gender Pathways program in
Northwestern Medicine as it happens
funny enough Northwestern Medicine
performs top surgeries so they did a
study to find out if the thing they're
already doing in making millions of
dollars from is good
and what do you know they found out that
it is in fact good
that's a result so convenient for them
that it's almost like they would
specifically engineer the result in
order to justify what they're already
doing and profiting from
and that's exactly what they did as it
turns out
so the study tracks 36 surgical patients
and then 34 control group patients all
from the same Metropolitan region we'll
have more on the control group in just a
moment but once again already we know
that this is bunk and we haven't even
gotten to the worst part yet but we know
that because you cannot arrive
at any truly scientific and generally
applicable conclusion based on a
selection of 36 test subjects all from
the same area and the same general
socioeconomic background
yet as mentioned that's not the worst of
it
the researchers here and by researchers
I mean people in the business of
engaging in the very practice they're
studying
followed up with with the surgical
patients they followed up three months
after surgery
three months
so Based on self-reported data
from the patient
three months post-opt post-op they've
concluded that transition regret is
basically not that doesn't happen it's
not a real concern
but but obviously regrets
doesn't generally set in after just
three months regret hits uh usually hits
its peak years after the fact
five seven Ten Years Later
for children especially the question is
not how they're going to feel about it
several weeks later
okay I don't need to know a girl who
gets Top surgery quote unquote at 14
I'm not as curious about how she feels
about it when she's 14 and a half
okay I want to know how she's going to
feel about it when she's 19. or when
she's 24 or when she's 30
. okay how will the adult version of her
feel about the decision made by the
child version
that's the question that I'm wondering
you cannot accurately measure regret
from any serious life decision three
months after the decision was made
that's the honeymoon period okay that's
when the forces of self-delusion are at
their strongest
when you've done something you've made a
decision that's going to impact the rest
of your life three months later you're
still in the mode of of convincing
yourself that it was the right thing to
do
the regret comes after you've gotten
past the self-delusion and you've gotten
to the point you know you you've uh uh
conjured up the courage to actually
confront what you did and to say this
was the wrong thing it doesn't happen
after three months
that's exactly why they cut the study
off precisely at that point
they had to decide what point to cut it
off and they chose three months
because they knew that if they chose
even six months or a year the results
would be very different
this is to say nothing of the
fundamental problem with self-reported
data in a study like this the people
involved
they know why the question is being
asked
okay that's the other thing you have to
ask in a study is is is this a blind
study okay blind study is the people
involved in the study the the the uh the
subjects they don't know what they're
doing or what the study is about or why
they're there
if it's not a blind study and the people
know why you're asking the question
then that's going to skew the results
they know that if they say they feel
regret it will be used to fuel what they
perceive as quote transphobic talking
points
so they have no incentive to be honest
and every incentive to paint a Rosy
picture
what about the control group well that
consisted of 36 dysphoric girls who did
not get surgery but still received
gender affirming care quote unquote
what that means is that every member of
the control group was on the path and in
the system that promotes surgery so if
they're asked whether they'd be happier
with surgery it's no wonder they'd say
yes a true control group would be gender
confused girls who received counseling
to help them accept and love their
female bodies
because that's the true alternative that
they should be testing against
but the faux researchers here ruled out
that possibility from the beginning
I haven't even told you the best part
uh you will find if you read it buried
deep within the bowels of this fake
study
the begrudging admission that 11
participants were not counted in the
final result because they were lost to
attrition
what does that mean
well it means they dropped out and they
stopped responding
now
why would participants drop out of a
study like this Midway through
why would they stop responding
especially if they felt great about what
they did why wouldn't they respond
could it be that they regretted the
surgery and were too embarrassed to talk
about it or else as mentioned they
didn't want to say anything that would
give ammo to the other side
is that what happened here
we can't say
the researchers didn't seem very curious
and curious enough to find out so we
don't know
but let's just make a very conservative
estimate
let's say that just about half let's say
six of the participants who were lost to
attrition would have if they responded
maybe had less than positive things to
say about the procedure
well that's true that would mean that
even with the deck stacked absurdly in
favor of surgery with the way the study
was conducted still 15 of these double
mastectomy victims regretted it almost
immediately
how might that number change if you
check back in a year two years or five
or ten
again we can't know for sure but we can
use our common sense
in fact Northwestern Medicine has been
doing top surgeries for more than three
months I'm pretty sure
so they themselves could have followed
up with surgery patients a year out two
years out three years I mean they
probably already have done that
but they didn't do that for this study
and we can make an educated guess as to
why
it's because they know what they're
going to hear
and it won't be what they want us to
hear
but there are lessons here that go
beyond the gender transition racket this
as we said at the top is is how lies are
told in the modern world so when you
hear about what the science has declared
it has often been declared this way
through cheap tricks and cherry picking
it can be very difficult to sort through
all of this we are bombarded by
information all the time some of it good
much of it garbage but it comes
constantly to us every day
the propagandists are counting on us
being too weary too exhausted too
overwhelmed to apply our critical
thinking capacities to what they say
that is basically the bet they're making
and it's up to us to make sure that it's
a Bad Bet
now let's get to our five headlines
inside every Progressive is a
totalitarian screaming to get out and
the team at front page magazine has been
unmasking these totalitarians since the
earliest days of the internet founded by
David Horowitz a former leftist who
ultimately became an enemy of the left
and a best-selling author front page
magazine has spent over two decades
combating the radical left's efforts to
destroy America there are two new
podcasts you have to check out are the
right take with Mark tapson and the
Jason Hill show they offer riveting
interviews in an insightful
um insights into uh politics culture and
current events the right take with Mark
tapson offers fascinating in-depth
cultural commentary as well as
interviews with well-known conservative
thinkers like Heather McDonald Michael
walshed Mary Grabber the Jason Hill show
offers thoughtful deep Dives about the
ideologies of the radical left and
interviews with renowned intellectuals
like Peter wood and Bruce Gilly it takes
a village to combat the radical left's
efforts to destroy America that's why as
a fan of my show you should also check
out these guys over at front page
magazine by visiting frontpagemag.com
and while you're there support their
cause by making a tax deductible
donation inside every Progressive is a
totalitarian screaming to get out and no
one understands that better than the
team at front page magazine so go check
out frontpagemag.com today
uh before we get to the first headline
this is
uh I I think something I want to read to
you because it's very relevant to what
we just talked about you know I said
well
we know what allegedly some of these Top
surgery the double mastectomy victims
and that is by the way we should start
calling them as victims not patients so
we know what the victims say some of
them anyway three months after the fact
what do they say a couple years later
well uh billboard Chris on Twitter is an
activist that has been traveling around
the country to expose uh gender ideology
and doing fantastic work he posted a
couple things to Twitter yesterday uh
from the D trans Reddit forum
where you hear you hear the testimony of
of girls who have been through this
who have been subjected to this who have
been victimized by it
and their stories are just
words Escape you and to describe it I
mean to call it tragic is is to
understate the case
so let me read a couple of these two
um here's one this is someone who's 17.
here's what she says
I hate my voice every time I open my
effing mouth I sound like a freak I've
ruined my life with my stupid decisions
I made as a kid
the doctors Ruined My Life by allowing a
barely functioning mentally ill child
with severe OCD and then undiagnosed BPD
to go on hormones that would completely
change my body
I can manage to get the pitch of my
voice up relatively decently to the
point where it's always in the
androgynous or low female range on a
vocal pitch app
there's always something that seems off
it never sounds female always like a
very high pitched stereotypical gay male
voice or a male trying to force a female
voice and failing
I'm tempted to just stop talking
altogether in my worst moments all I
want to do is tear out my vocal cords
and be done with it
I've been on T for about two years as
testosterone although it was relatively
sporadic and it wasn't very consistent
with either the gel or the shots at all
I've only just managed to get off the
hormones now as the shots I was on were
very three were were every three months
thankfully not a lot else changed while
on testosterone no facial hair no facial
changes and I never went through with
any surgeries I'm still only 17. I've
tried watching YouTube videos like trans
voice lessons and absolutely nothing in
the in the videos makes any sense and I
don't find them helpful in the slightest
I'm legitimately suicidal because of the
decisions I made as a kid it's all my
fault
I don't know how I how long I can keep
doing this
well it's not her fault at all
of course this is what the kids are left
with they're left to feel like it is
their fault when it is entirely the
fault of the doctors and the parents who
allowed this to happen entirely their
fault 100 percent
and this by the way this is there's no
surgery here this is just quote just
from the testosterone
which we're assured is reversible it's
not irreversible
so this is what a child goes through
after changing
her voice
now what happens
when they go further than that
this is another one this is from another
user on the d-trans Reddit form
I'm a 17 year old girl with a flat chest
a deep voice a visible Adam's apple and
some facial hair there's no reason for
me to continue to live I destroyed my
life and I feel like all I have is
stupid for me to have all the hope I
have is stupid for me to have I don't
think any person will ever want to date
me before all this people were into me
but I destroyed that now no one is ever
going to like me there's nothing I can
really do without getting reminded of my
past and how much I miss it I feel
ashamed of what I did I'm scared that
people will never let me do decisions on
my own anymore
I was just a kid and I would have needed
someone to help me accept myself but my
therapist didn't question my transness
I can't stop thinking about the life I
could have had
I also think other people will now
believe that there's something better
than me
I love my mom she's an amazing mom she
stopped me the first time from
transitioning but the second time she
was also brainwashed and sadly thought
that when all these professionals say
it's the right thing to let your kid
transition then it must be the right
thing she thinks it's all her fault but
it isn't I want to kill myself but then
she'll feel even more miserable how can
I kill myself and let her know that I
want her to be happy I'm 17.
why do I have to think about ending my
life it's too much for me to handle
there's no joy in my life anymore
so this is a this child is 17 years old
and got the surgery there's another uh
post where she talks about she got the
surgery when she was 14.
so this is three years later and we
don't know exactly based on this when
the regrets started to set in but three
years later
so you follow up three years later still
childhood
and this is what you find
as I said words uh
cannot quite do justice
to the enormity of of the evil here the
the depths of the evil
the people who are pushing this and
promoting it are as I have said many
times and I and I believe with every
fiber of my being these are among the
worst human beings
the ones who are pushing and promoting
it and doing it
two kids
are among the worst human beings who
have ever lived on the planet
I mean they they belong in the same
category the Nazi comparisons and all
the rest of it are tired and overplayed
but but they belong right in that
category
in the category of the most monstrous
uh
demons to have ever walked the face of
the Earth
and there are a lot of other things that
we talk about
you know in our society a lot of other
issues we deal with other issues that I
talk about all the time and then we'll
talk about today on the show but
I can tell you right now and I'm not
going to be around to say I told you so
but uh
history books in the future
like this is the only thing they're
going to be worried about with our our
whole era of history in western
civilization will be defined by this
they will be writing books and history
books focused almost entirely on this
okay it's like when history books talk
about the 1860s uh in in the United
States it's there are other things that
happen besides the Civil War but the
Civil War is the only thing the history
books are concerned about in the 1860s
well when the when the history books
tell of the 2010s and the 2020s
this is what that chapter is going to be
about
and there are going to be debates raging
among historians for centuries to come
just trying to figure out how could this
have happened
they'll be baffled by like how could
this have happened how did how did
anyone allow it to happen
and I'm living through it I'm asking the
same question
so this month Governor Younkin in
Virginia instituted policies of Virginia
schools these are very simple Common
Sense policies uh like you know the left
talks about common sense gun reform
that's not really common sense at all
but in this case these really are common
sense reforms if you will uh and the
rules stipulate that everyone can use
only bathrooms and locker rooms that
align with their biological sex and also
that a child's gender identity quote
unquote cannot be concealed from the
parents so the rules don't even say that
a child can't uh identify as whatever
they want to identify in school
the rules only say the policy only says
that the parents have a right to know
what's going on with their kid in school
you can't you can't conceal that from
the parents so that's it that's the rule
in other words the rule
puts Virginia schools in line with the
rules that were in every school that's
ever existed up until nine minutes ago
but that led to this as reported by NBC
News students across Virginia protested
Tuesday in response to new guidelines
putting restrictions on transgender
students in the state's Public Schools
it's actually not true at all there are
no restrictions at all the the the
policies are the same for everyone use
the bathroom that aligns with your sex
parents can know what's happening with
their kids so there are no special
restrictions being put on anyone
it's the same restrictions for everyone
uh walkouts are set to take place
throughout the day of more than 90
middle and high schools in the state
according to the student-run advocacy
group Pride Liberation project which
organized the Statewide effort yeah I'm
sure that's really student-run
organizing a Statewide effort
um there's no adult influence there at
all is there
as of noon on Tuesday students in
Woodbridge spring Springfield Manassas
and other Virginia cities were waving
rainbow picket signs and shouting trans
rights or human rights now
the left of course is making a big deal
out of the walkouts as if it proves
something and it does prove something
first of all it proves that kids will
take advantage of any opportunity to
miss class which you know is
understandable from a kid's perspective
and also that the peer pressure to go
along with this is immense
I mean if if kids are walking out and
you're one of the kids who doesn't then
now you've just outed yourself as a
quote-unquote transfo so you have to be
out there and also it shows that kids
have been sufficiently brainwashed so
that even some of these girls many of
them probably who go to these schools
will protest against policies that grant
them safety and respect
okay so they are protesting against
their own dignity and safety
because they're kids they don't know any
better
one such student was interviewed on
cable news is on MSNBC and let's listen
to a little bit of that
tell us about these walkouts today do
you think they delivered the message
I think looking at social media looking
across the press that we've received
today I really think that we got the
message across that we wanted to which
is Virginia students are not Behind
These proposed guidelines
Governor yonkin's team is telling NBC
News in a statement partly that when
parents are part of the process schools
will accommodate the requests of
children and their families adding
parents should be a part of their
children's lives I wonder how you'd
respond to that
of course these proposed regulations are
not about parental rights they really
were about parental rights then Governor
yonkin would be looking at things like
expanding access to democracy in
Virginia this isn't about parental
rights this is about attacking Virginia
students
we also hear that Governor yonkin
doesn't think that students understand
how harmful these policies can be
countless students in Virginia have read
these policies and understand that the
real implications are not to protect the
rights of parents but instead to deny
our identity our humanity and our very
existence
you know I actually feel sorry for this
girl uh of course I do because she's
just a kid she's in high school so she's
I don't know
maybe five or six years older than than
my own kids at most
um and unlike what you hear maybe from
some older leftists especially elected
Democrats who are going on and on about
trans rights and they don't believe
anything they're saying she believes it
she totally believes it now she might be
repeating lines that she's been given
that's for sure but she still basically
believes it's the extent that she
understands what she's saying she does
believe it
denying the right to exist denying our
right to exist what but
Your Existence is negated by having to
use a bathroom that the the same
bathroom policy that every human on
earth has followed
Your Existence is threatened by that how
well she's a kid she's not thinking it
through
but it
you know the fact it doesn't make any
sense doesn't matter
I mean indoctrinate kids into this at a
at a at a stage when they don't really
have critical thinking
faculties uh certainly not fully
developed ones
so they're not they're actually not
capable of thinking through all this
stuff
and if the left has their way they'll
they'll never be capable of it
speaking of someone who doesn't have
critical thinking skills this is another
great moment on CNN it's almost as good
as that lady giving Don Lemon a lesson
about the history of slavery which one
of my favorite all-time cable news Clips
was from a couple weeks ago if you
remember uh this is maybe not quite that
good but it's this is still great stuff
so here is um
Don Lemon
uh reporting on the hurricane and trying
to get his guest to make it a lecture on
climate change and the guest is just not
having it let's watch
can you tell us what this is and what
effect climate change has on this
phenomenon
we can come back and talk about climate
change at a later time I want to focus
on the here and now we think the rapid
intensification is probably almost done
there could be a little bit more
intensification as it's still over the
warm Waters of the Eastern Gulf of
Mexico but I don't think we're going to
get any more rapid intensification if
you look here you can actually see
pretty interesting for your viewers you
can actually see a second Iowa wall
forming around the inner eye wall and
that's basically the second eye wall has
overtaken the original eyewall and that
should arrest development uh so listen I
just I'm just trying to get that you
said you want to talk about climate
change but what what effect does climate
change have on this phenomenon that that
is happening now because it seems these
storms are intensifying that's the
question I don't think you can link
climate change to any one event on the
whole on the cumulative climate change
may be making storms worse but to link
it to any one event
I would caution against them okay well
listen I grew up there and these storms
are intensifying something is causing
them to intensify
I just can't I mean his job is on the
line and he's I just can't stop
embarrassing himself and I I love that
of course what you just heard there is
is
the case like
uh first of all when when we're dealing
when a hurricane is bearing down on us
or bearing down on Florida
um conversations about climate change
are abstract and academic and totally
useless they're not going to do anything
for us right now even if it's true that
that climate change like you driving
your car to work actually cause you
yourself during your commute you you
scumbag you villain you have caused this
hurricane even if that was true that
doesn't do anything for us now
okay now we got to deal with just like
the the reality of this hurricane how do
we respond to it and that's what he's
trying to talk about but Don Lemon wants
to take in the other direction
of course as he points out that's not
true you can't at most when it comes to
climate change you can talk in in
general broad Strokes you can't take one
specific event and just declare that
this is happening because of climate
change so what you're saying is that if
not for
alleged man-made climate change this
hurricane wouldn't exist or it wouldn't
be as serious like this specific
hurricane would not be happening or
wouldn't be as serious if not for people
driving their cars to work how could you
possibly know that
even based on the left Zone logic
you could accept everything they tell
you about climate change
just accept it uncritically which you
shouldn't by the way as we've already
gone over you shouldn't accept
uncritically anything they say ever
about anything
but um
even if you did it's you still can't
draw the connection to one specific
event
and we know that because hurricanes
I I just keep saying it's like a blew in
the face but hurricanes have always
happened and you can now Don Lemon might
say well I grew up in Florida I remember
hurricanes have gotten more serious
that's a yeah there's some anecdotal
data
uh okay well Don Lemon was experienced
some hurricanes and he knows that these
are worse
well if you're doing the anecdotal thing
I mean I've I've never lived in a in a
hurricane
prone area but I have been watching
unfortunately cable news since I was a a
child
and what I know is that the media
every single hurricane season has said
that it's the worst season ever and that
every hurricane is a monster it's the
worst thing that's ever going to happen
and then sometimes it actually pans out
in the hurricane like this that might
well be looks like that's gonna be the
case with this one the hurricane
actually is as bad as they say but but I
know the media says that about every
hurricane and every hurricane season and
that's been the case for as long as I
can remember
so there's my anecdote in competition
with uh with Don Lemons
you can also go it doesn't take long to
go you can you can go online and look up
uh deadliest hurricanes in history worst
hurricanes most serious hurricanes and
you're gonna find
uh dates going back to like the 1600s
of course when you when you start going
farther and farther back it's there
aren't as many records
so how do we even know like if if
if the worst hurricane
in history
hit Florida in let's say the year I
don't know 1307.
how would we know that
there wasn't there were people around
but there weren't people around keeping
reliable historical records about these
things measuring wind gusts and
everything they didn't have satellite
data certainly
so how do we even know it
it's one of the problems you run into
when you start making declarations about
this is the worst weather event in
history how could how could you possibly
know that
when there have been serious weather
events occurring on the face of the
Earth for billions of years and we've
only been keeping records of them for I
mean comparatively we've basically been
keeping records reliable records for uh
for five seconds
in comparison to the whole history of
humanity and certainly of the
of the Earth itself
that's the problem uh not that it Don
Lemon really sees it as a problem Deli
wire has this report Oregon has spent
more than 300 million dollars on
services for drug addicts but experts
are warning lawmakers that the state's
efforts are not working since Oregon uh
effectively decriminalized drugs in 2020
the state has poured about 302 million
dollars into addiction and Social
Services for addicts but the overdose
rate death rate rather has only risen
largely driven by the influx of fentanyl
last week the Oregon Health Authority
OHA announced that it finally awarded
the 302 million dollars to non-profits
working to combat addiction the funding
was the first round of Grants awarded
under Oregon's drug decriminalization
law measure 110 which decriminalized
possession of small amounts of most hard
drugs including cocaine heroin LSD and
methamphetamine the laws grant program
uses tax dollars from marijuana sales
for Addiction Services the grant money
goes to pay for services not cover
covered by Medicaid such as Outreach
peer mentors housing and clean needles
for intravenous drug use
so that's part of what's happening is
we're actually in order to help with
drug secession help people get over
their drug addiction in Oregon anyway
and in other states as well they're
facilitating drug abuse they're making
drug abuse
easier
easier make it easier to access drug
paraphernalia so they can engage in drug
use
I will say this is one thing that I've
been wrong about it's not often that I
say that on this show but I I've never
been a proponent of decriminalize
decriminalizing all drugs I've never
said we should decriminalize heroin and
methamphetamine I've always recognized
that as insane but I did go through a
period I mean up until recently where I
said that you know we we probably should
just make pot legal or at least
decriminalize it and I had all the
standard Arguments for it the cost of
enforcement the fact that pot arguably
isn't much more physically dangerous
than alcohol et cetera et cetera et
cetera all those arguments you're
familiar with many of which you've
probably made yourself
but I I've since come to realize
and that for me was a change I used to
be able to ban all drugs and I said oh
well marijuana okay I can see the
argument now I'm now I'm going back to I
think you just got to ban all this stuff
ban it all
um
we've seen what happens
we were promised certain results from
decriminalizing drugs whether it's all
drugs or just certain drugs whatever it
is we were promised certain results and
those results simply have not come about
I mean has the drug abuse problem gotten
any better in any City or any state
where they've decriminalized any of
these drugs
the only changes I can tell a lot of
cities anyways you can't walk down the
street without smell you smell marijuana
everywhere like everybody is high all
the time in public in a lot of these
cities and then uh the drug abuse
problem for many of the harder drugs has
only gotten worse
is that because we decriminalize
marijuana well there might not be a
direct connection I think there's a
there's probably a connection but it
might not be one directly led to the
other
and you could point out that we were
that we were trending in this Direction
with um the drug abuse drug drug
overdose epidemic before marijuana was
was decriminalized but even so we were
made certain promises
and many of these issues were blamed at
least in part on drug prohibition
well you lift drug prohibition and the
problems only get worse
why is that well I I think because
what we're learning is that people who
are addicted to drugs
will remain addicted whether it's legal
or not
uh all we can decide as a society is
whether we will strongly
stigmatize and punish this Behavior or
not
and is it better to be in a society that
stigmatizes
drug use or is it better to be in one
that just opens up the door and says
yeah do whatever you want
well you could stigmatize it and
criminalize it you're not going to get
rid of it we all understand that
but is it better to live in a society
where people are just literally laying
on the sidewalk
using drugs passing out overdosing
so you walk walking through a city means
you have to step over the bodies of uh
people of OD'd on God knows what
is that an improvement I mean that that
is what it looks like we've discovered
when you get rid of this stigma
and you also get rid of the legal
penalties on these drugs
seems like a massive mistake to me
here's a clip of um
mayor Eric Adams in New York trying to I
guess Elevate his own city and state by
putting down others classic bully move I
guess
here he is
we have a brand
New York has a brand
and when people see it
it means something
you know when we go there it's not
Kansas doesn't have a brand
you know when you go there you okay
you're from Kansas
no well you know what
you know I I didn't think it was
possible I really didn't think it was
possible that
and I was wrong about this too I didn't
think it'd be possible for New York to
elect a mayor who's a bigger douchebag
than Bill de Blasio like it just didn't
seem possible I mean he he was he was
the Uber douchebag he was like you you
couldn't get more than him and then and
now we have Eric Adams
who who's given him a run for his money
now Eric Adams he's not as sort of
lumbering and Goofy he doesn't he
doesn't look like Gumby had a baby with
Rex Ryan like uh like Bill de Blasio
does but he's he's he's really up there
as far as being a tool
New York has a brand I agree by the way
New York does have a brand
the brand is uh here's New York's brand
unlivable overpriced oh that's that's
New York's brand
and part of the brand is everyone who
lives there is super proud of how
terrible it is
and uh and and feels that it's it's very
special it's part of the culture
what is your culture
dirt and rats and feces all over the all
over the sidewalk people overdosing on
drugs crime
it's gray and
grimy and it smells
but we have restaurants
and little cute little stores we can go
shopping
okay yeah they said so you have a
convenience as a consumer is what you
have that's your brand
your brand is that there are a lot of
Brands all around trying to sell you
things walk down times squares Brands
everywhere now New York doesn't have a
brand it has a lot of different brands
competing for your attention
who wants to even live in a place that
has a brand whatever that means
that's actually the advantage of living
in Kansas now
um so I'm not exactly sure what it means
for a place to have a brand I do know
what it means for a place to have kind
of a a personality a culture
I know you go out into Kansas and people
are very nice for one thing
you can find great barbecue
um
and there's also space that there's
actual space and that that's part of the
advantage of living
somewhere that isn't in the city
so you don't have you don't have a brand
you can actually you can be you can like
raise a family and and and have your own
sort of identity as a family
and you're not being constantly crowded
by a million other people
that's the advantage you're gonna live
your own life
which is what people in Kansas want to
do
all right one other thing here let's see
uh this is from page six it says popular
YouTube group The try guys fired its
member Ned Fulmer as he admitted to
cheating on his wife Ariel Fulmer the
group's Instagram page said Ned falmers
no longer working with the try guys
um as a result of a thorough internal
review we do not see a path forward we
thank you for your support as we
navigate this change
less than an hour later Ned 35 addressed
the news on his personal Instagram
account
he said family should have always been
my priority but I lost focus and had a
consensual workplace relationship
I'm sorry for any pain my actions have
caused to the guys the fans but most of
all to Ariel
so there's the news on the try guys and
this comes on the heels of news about a
Dude Perfect the YouTube
page you dude perfect and they're gonna
be building it's positive news they're
apparently building an actual stadium so
the YouTube channel Dude Perfect is
building a stadium for themselves
apparently and I read that headline a
couple days ago and these two stories
together raise the question
who the hell are any of these people
I I've never heard of either of them
until this week
and they're trending all over social
media everyone's talking about them
um I still don't understand exactly who
they are or why or why anyone cares or
what they do but this kind of goes to
show that yes I'm out of touch horribly
so I admit that also though it shows
that there has been this
right there's it in like every week it's
another YouTuber or Tick Tock person
who's all over the headlines and
trending people are talking about and
then I along with the other old fogies
Among Us I look at that I say who I
don't know who who are they and what
even do they do
I I just I don't know at least when you
hear about a pop star or something
you've never heard of you it's like you
haven't heard of this person but you
understand the concept of pop music and
so you know at least that's what they do
and how they became famous a lot of
these people now I'm not sure what they
do
um
part of that is this total fracturing
and splintering of the culture and we do
take for granted you know we take for
granted that kids will have different
celebrities different pop culture
figures that they're into and that that
is relatively normal from a from a
modern perspective anyway you can go
back to Elvis you know and back then uh
the kids were into Elvis and the adults
thought he that he was a harbinger of
evil
and kind of turns out that the adults
were actually correct about that because
uh when you take into account what pop
music became over time I think that they
were basically right
but anyway at least back then
the adults knew who Elvis was
even if they thought he was terrible
and when I was a kid in the 90s the kids
had their pop stars like we had our pop
stars
um and and the adults didn't really
follow it that closely but they at least
knew who the people were for the most
part
um the adults in the 90s maybe were a
little bit less clued in just because
there were more pop culture figures to
keep track of
but now you go another 20 or 30 years in
the future
and kids sort of exist
in their own
Universe they have their own landscape
entirely their own little bubble
universe
with their own celebrities and nobody
even knows who these people are or what
they do there's very little shared
culture from generation to generation
there's actually none at all
which which is a problem
one other thought related to this
this is another Scandal of a famous
person apparently famous person
who is caught cheating being unfaithful
um and this is something men are now
getting in trouble for Adam Levine who
is someone at least I do know who that
is he's another one who got in trouble
for that for cheating
and um and that's fine with me because I
think that if you cheat you commit
adultery you should be shamed publicly
for that especially if you're a famous
person you've kind of agreed to live
your life on the public stage whether
you like it or not adultery is a
terrible thing and if people react to it
accordingly then that's that's good
that's how we should react
but we can only shame them publicly if
we're admitting that there is more to
sexual morality than mere consent
right because as this guy what's his
name again Ned whatever he says it was a
consensual workplace relationship
which is kind of a weird and creepy way
to put it when you're describing an
affair but that's what he said and it's
true it was a consensual relationship
now usually what we hear from the left
and from the culture is as long as it's
consensual it's fine
this was consensual for the two people
involved and it's not fine
and I agree that it's not fine because
there's more tickets like consent is
Baseline of course you need to have
consent in a sexual relationship
otherwise it's not a relationship at all
it's rape
um but that's not the end of it
things like Fidelity and loyalty and
love and dignity all of these things are
important as well
and if you remove all of those but you
still have consent
it is a disordered and bad thing
so I guess what I'm saying is I have
kind of the moral framework and maybe
you have the moral framework to condemn
guys who cheat on their wives but a lot
of these leftists especially who are
making a big deal out of this what they
don't have the framework for it
unless they're going to admit that they
were wrong about sexual morality this
whole time
in which case
I'm I'm happy to have them on board
let's get now to the comment section
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well the left has proclaimed an all-out
war on childhood having a will in place
is the least you could do to protect
your kids a will gives you the power to
decide who will raise your kids should
something happen to you and your spouse
without one you know the state decides
that we don't want that to happen a will
it's all about protecting your legacy
protecting your finances protecting your
kids ensuring that your medical
decisions are honored when you're unable
to see them through deciding who will
take on the responsibility of raising
your children or caring for a parent or
a grandparent a will may be your only
opportunity to direct important family
heirlooms financial investments and
responsibilities to the proper people in
your life plus it's incredibly easy and
affordable with epic will epic will
bundles your last will living will uh
Healthcare power of attorney hippo
release and durable Financial power of
attorney it only costs 119 dollars for a
single person to create a will and win
you use promo code Walsh you save an
extra 10 so it's even more affordable
than that go to epicworld.com use promo
code Walsh to save 10 on Epic Wheels
complete will package that's
epicwill.com promo code Walsh
first comment says Matt in response to
the tick tock dating advice segment on
Monday I can vouch that hat-based
relationships are strong 23 years ago my
wife asked me about the ridiculous
Fisherman's hat I wore at the time and
we've been through the ups and downs of
19 years of marriage and four kids and
now are stronger than ever the Hat
tattered and worn now hangs on my 12
year old son's bedpost I think he keeps
it because he senses that it's the rock
our family is built on
hey you know the dating sites and and uh
you know Tinder and everything not
working for a lot of people
hear the complaints all the time it was
it wouldn't work for me if I was still
in the dating scene thank God I'm not so
maybe it's time to try some different
try some different strategies wear a
weird hat out in public and maybe
someone will come up and ask you about
it it's a conversation starter so you
worked for this guy
23 years of marriage built on the
foundation of a hat
um doc says Dr Bailey says when I was a
medical student at Vanderbilt a long
long time ago if you saw residents
postgraduate special training in the
hospital parking lot you could
immediately tell if he she was OB GYN
the OB GYN drove Cadillacs and other
expensive cars as the other residents
drove crap cars because that's all they
could afford the OB gyns had very
lucrative side jobs as abortionists
so there's a long history of screw it
I'm here for the money at these
institutions
long history of that there's also a long
history which starts well maybe it
doesn't start with abortion but one of
the worst manifestations is abortion
where you've got people in the medical
field who maybe through
maybe often you know through their
throughout their day they actually are
treating and helping people
which is what you're supposed to do in
medicine you're supposed to treat help
cure that's that's all you're supposed
to do Do no harm
um and yet through abortion
the objective is exactly the opposite
you're not treating anything
you you are you are harming on purpose
which is a total inversion of the
medical profession
same thing with the quote-unquote gender
affirmation procedures JR says Matt
sounds like Cartman well trying to
pronounce latinae in all of its goofball
examples yeah there's a little bit of a
carbon there I guess but that's that's
gender that's the new gender neutral you
don't want to see Latino or Latina it's
a Latina
Latina
the other thing I'd even mentioned
yesterday is just
drop the last letter if it's really this
important to you you could just say
Latin that that actually works you know
you see if it's so important to you to
not have a a not signify a gender
then you don't need to add some other
letter to the end
just say Latin
or Or Hispanic
also gender neutral there you go
um
and uh cotco 5 says Matt Reading off the
job description for web developers put a
smile on my face
you know what reading a prompter is
actually
difficult people don't realize this
difficult for me anyway as a [ __ ] but
if I write the the stuff in the prompter
then I can read it but if you're reading
something that you didn't write and you
don't really understand it it it's it's
more difficult than you think that's why
you know I don't make fun of
other people when they stumble on the
prompter Joe Biden
well I guess I do all the time
I'm not going to stop
well there are two ways to absolutely
stop the left in its tracks the first is
to point out their lunacy the second is
to take as much money away from them as
possible and if you're a regular
listener to this show you're already
doing the former if you made the
decision to stop supporting Harry's
razors and go with Jeremy's then you're
doing both right now but if you haven't
heard yet we've got a brand new
incentive for you it's the Jeremy's
razors contest for the car here's how it
works for every person you prefer
whether they buy a Jeremy's Razor's kit
or a daily wire annual membership you
both you both get points in the race to
win the god Kings McLaren if someone
from the sweet baby gang wins this thing
it would warm my heart I will never
drive a car like this because I'm
driving to 12 passenger lunker all
around but if you win it I would be very
happy with that most of the top players
haven't hit the 20 referral Mark yet so
there's still plenty of time for the for
you to jump in the race and also win it
to sign up and start competing go to
jeremy'sraisers.com play the race for
the car ends on November 1st so get in
the competition today see terms and
conditions for complete details
jeremy'srazors.com referral terms the
program is open only to legal U.S
residents residing in the U.S D.C
excluding residents of Colorado
Connecticut Maryland Puerto Rico and U.S
territories and possessions 18 and older
remember friends don't let friends shave
with woke razors now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
quitting which is the new Modern Trend
where employees essentially stop trying
but they remain on the job attempting to
Sail by on minimal effort doing the bare
minimum this was a movement pioneered by
gen Z with a big assist from Millennials
who are always eager to join any Trend
especially one that involves being lazy
of course I say the movement was
pioneered by gen Z but they in fact did
not invent laziness though they are the
only generation maybe narcissistic
enough to think that they did no they
invented the phrase and the hashtag and
The Tick Tock video is promoting it and
now the makers of quiet quitting are
back with a new hit called hashtag act
your wage
this is another viral Trend which is
essentially the same thing as quiet
quitting sort of taking the Marvel
approach where the sequel is a carbon
copy of the original the ACT your wage
Trend which has taken off on Tick Tock
is apparently best explained by this
viral video which has millions of views
from Tick Tock user Sarai Marie let's uh
take a look
Veronica I'm going to have you take this
home and work on it tonight okay
respectfully Susan I'd rather spend time
with my family
Veronica did you just decline the zoom
meeting that's at 6 30 tonight
oh yeah I did I did do that yeah because
it's outside of my working hours nine to
five so I won't be attending
all right Veronica I do need you to be
available during your vacation okay
Susan you'll be blocked on my vacation
because I won't be answering
okay Veronica I'm gonna need you to
complete all this today
Susan do I look like two people to you
no oh okay just making sure because that
looks like the work of two people right
right and I'm one I'm just one person
right
and it's time to go home five o'clock
hey thank you bye
it would appear that uh
acting your wage means being so grating
and annoying and shrilled that you end
up sitting alone in an empty corner of
the office because everybody else has
jumped out the window now if you're
still confused about what this movement
is supposed to be the New York Post has
more details quote the video is tagged
act your wage a hashtag that is a mass
37.6 million views and counting on Tick
Tock it's part of a movement among young
workers to only do what they're paid for
and no more and to urge their co-workers
to do the same proponents of act your
wage see it as setting a firm healthy
boundary in the workplace acting your
wage might sound similar to quiet
quitting which became the biggest
buzzword in the office as a Summer Games
event but there's a fine line between
the two movements well motivation is the
bridge between the two but there's still
two very different in separate
constructs Maisha and Martin head of
people analytics of the software company
work human told the post in short quiet
quitters are doing the bare minimum and
trying to get away with it while the ACT
your Wagers are doing exactly what
they're paid to do not more and not less
don't I mean they're all just a bunch of
lazy bastards in other words for a real
world example of this phenomenon um not
that anyone needs a real word example of
laziness I think we all kind of get it
but Insider has an article about acting
your wage and it tells the story of a 22
year old cashier named Claire
and this is kind of important for a
point we're going to make here this is
what it says Claire is adamant about
acting your wage she has watched
psychological the store being fully
staffed where workers feel they can have
a life outside the job and then
something happens to upset the balance
whether it's management changing workers
hours or a particularly demanding
customer and co-worker after co-worker
walks out quote if the job is something
I can do and it's not taking from my
life more than it gives I.E the money
then I can withstand fussy customers and
strange management I can brush all that
off she said I do understand there are
times when a job is just not worth it
though for Claire who makes about 13 an
hour in Texas the job is still worth it
but that's because she acts her wage she
does what she's expected to do but
doesn't take on more or stretch herself
more than she needs to it's another side
of quiet quitting and it's a practice
that she thinks is especially important
for Gen Z
quote I have control over when I show up
and when I leave she said while I'm
there I'm going to try at least to do as
I'm told but I'm not going to do a nine
to nine for Claire acting her wage is
all about keeping her identity separate
from work and not feeling the need to go
above and beyond
yes don't go above and beyond that is
indeed the Timeless Mantra of losers and
mediocre nobodies everywhere
now we should first note here as we did
with the Quiet quitting trip
the proponents of this approach do in
theory make a couple of valid points so
it's true that you should have a life
outside of work
it's also true that you need to know how
to set boundaries not just at work but
in general so you don't get taken
advantage of but both of these potential
positives are ultimately neutralized
because for one thing
there is no real value in ensuring that
you have extra time outside of work if
you aren't going to spend that extra
time doing something enriching and
worthwhile
so most of these people will just go
home and scroll through Tick Tock that's
how they're spending that extra time we
heard in the video that Veronica
wanted to spend more time with her
family but the problem is that these
days most people in their 20s don't have
families so by family they really mean
their couch their phone and their HBO
Max subscription
and and if you have to choose between
putting some extra hours in at work
and staring like a zombie at a glowing
screen for six hours until you fall into
a drooling stupor and eventually Drift
Off to Sleep
I think the former is often a better
choice
second setting boundaries is important
but in the adult world you need to know
how to do that with a certain amount of
tact and diplomacy
so the real trick is to be firm and
clear and yet not obnoxious
but the problem in the video
uh what the video is recommending is
that employees act like a bunch of
spoiled toddlers turning up the smarmy
level to 100 screeching like overgrown
bats and acting uh offended their boss
would even ask them to do a little bit
extra
let's see you can't it's what you have
to understand kids you cannot talk to
your boss that way you might you might
wish that you could but you can't
so in the real world or your boss comes
up to you now I'm not doing that
seriously get the hell out of here this
is not a movie you can't talk to people
that way
this this might be how you your parents
may allow you to talk to them that way
and that's why and that's why you never
learn the lesson
but in reality you can't it's a good way
to get yourself fired in the real world
if you're only going to do the bare
minimum and on top of that you're also
unpleasant disrespectful and irritating
there's no reason for your employer to
keep you around any longer than it takes
to find some other warm body to sit in
your chair
you have to always ask yourself that
question I know we don't want to ask
ourselves this question because it's a
difficult question yes but but you know
at your job or whatever you're doing
it's like you have to ask yourself
um what what role am I really serving am
I even needed
and if you if you've made yourself
Expendable that's going to be a problem
for you
and making yourself Expendable it's
certainly one way to approach life the
other way to approach it is to strive to
be indispensable invaluable
undeniable
but that takes effort and it takes
Talent
and here's an important point it takes
time
so it's quite notable that gen Z they're
pushing you know these Trends
um apparently deciding that working hard
going above and beyond running the extra
mile Etc is not worth the strain the
cost benefit calculation doesn't work
out in their favor they say
Claire you know the cashier she's a ride
to this conclusion and yet Claire is is
22 years old
at the upper generational range the
oldest members of gen Z would be like 25
or 26.
how could you possibly have determined
already in your mid-20s after having
been in the Working World for a few
years at most
that there's no point in putting an
extra effort
I mean you've decided already that the
whole thing's a suckers game
what did you work one overtime shift and
then decide that ambition is pointless
what did you expect
did you think you'd put in five extra
hours behind the cash register at the
grocery store and the next day they'd
make you CEO of Krogers
well I spent one entire whole day trying
hard and I haven't become a millionaire
yet so I give up
that's not the way the Life Works
not everything follows the rules of
instant gratification
you can't always get results in 60
seconds or less
the whole world is not a microwave it
doesn't work that way success comes
slowly and painfully and with lots of
Peaks and valleys valleys and
frustrations and with stops and starts
and with hardship
now speaking personally
I am now at a point in my career where
I'm willing to say that I am having some
success I'm not done not nearly I'm not
satisfied not even close but I've hit
certain Milestones that are important to
me that I've been working towards and uh
and so you know and that's a good thing
do you know how long that took
like a decade and a half more than that
actually
and you're given up after what three
months
you're ready to quiet quit when you're
just quiet started last week how fast do
you think success comes
we said hard work pays off we never said
it pays off in 30 seconds
life is not an ATM you can't just press
a button and the cash comes out it takes
longer a lot longer to get the payout
but here's the good news
if you're a younger person
and you're just starting out in your
career
the deck has been cleared okay many of
your peers are are settling for
mediocrity already they haven't even
tried yet
and they've decided there's no point in
trying
they they totaled their cars on the
first speed bump they came across they
ran into a mild Breeze and were knocked
on their asses and have no interest in
getting up
this is an opportunity for you
if you're not one of those people
as long as you have slightly more
fortitude and a slightly better work
ethic
than all those other losers you have an
opportunity
you'll you only need to be slightly more
useful than a slug to set yourself apart
and then imagine if you went above and
beyond even that
imagine if you really tried
the stage is set for you to succeed
while your competition makes Tick Tock
videos explaining why they aren't even
trying
let them be satisfied with a lackluster
life filled with indifference and
excuses
you show up early you take the overtime
you take on the extra projects you look
to make your job more challenging not
easier
let them be cynical about it and scoff
about what are you even trying for
let them do it because you're climbing
the ladder while they're all crowding
around the Bottom Rung
hoping someone pays off the rest of
their student loans
one day you'll be the boss
and you can gather together all of these
low effort lumps on a log and tell them
all at once
as I tell them now
you're all canceled
and that'll do it for today
for this portion of the show anyway as
we move over to the members block
hope to see you there if not Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign